Sure, the Democrats are doing great in the polls this week, but to consider where they are as a party, consider please the case of Joe Cabazuela, a middle class guy, used to vote Democratic, lives in San Diego, in a state that the Democrats have to take if they're going to take the White House. And let's begin with this fact about him. Although his parents emigrated from Mexico and eventually became citizens, he says that his entire family is in favor of proposition 187, the law that would deny public services to illegal aliens, no public schooling, no social services.
当然，民主党本周在民调中表现出色，但要考虑他们作为一个政党的处境，请考虑一下乔·卡巴祖埃拉的案例。他是个中产阶级，过去一直投给民主党，住在圣迭戈，住在民主党想要赢得白宫就必须拿下的州。让我们先从关于他的一个事实开始：尽管他的父母是从墨西哥移民来的并最终成为了公民，但他表示他的全家都支持187号提案，即那项剥夺非法移民公共服务的法律，没有公共教育，也没有社会福利。
To me, I don't think they should get a free education. If they want an education, they want to come over here, let them pay for it. Me, as a Mexican-American, I cannot go over there and get it. Their government is not supplying the needs of the people over there. That's why they're coming over here, because this government's giving it away free. Charge them for it. That's the way I see it.
对我来说，我不认为他们应该得到免费教育。如果他们想要教育，如果他们想来这里，就让他们自己付钱。我作为一个墨西哥裔美国人，我可没法去那里得到教育。他们的政府没有满足那里人民的需求。这就是为什么他们来到这里，因为这个政府在免费赠送这些。让他们自己付费吧。我就是这么看的。
He says he voted Democratic most his life. And then, when George Bush ran for president, he just started seeing things differently. And although he, himself, had been on and off welfare a couple times, and although his daughter has been on welfare for five years herself, what the Republicans were saying, especially about welfare, made a lot of sense to him.
他说他一生中大部分时间都投给民主党。然后，当乔治·布什竞选总统时，他开始以不同的眼光看问题。尽管他自己也曾几次接受过福利救济，而且他的女儿也已经领了五年的福利救济，但共和党人所说的，特别是关于福利的内容，对他来说很有道理。
Because I could be on disability if I wanted to. Because of my legs I am disabled. I've had three surgeries. But I refuse to sit at home and watch TV and collect a monthly check. That's not me. I believe that that's what made this country great, is the fact that we can work.
因为如果我想的话，我可以领残疾救济金。因为腿的原因，我是残疾人。我做过三次手术。但我拒绝坐在家里看电视，然后每个月领一张支票。那不是我。我相信，能够工作才是这个国家伟大的原因。
The Republicans seem to share these middle class values. When I asked him if he liked any of the things that Democrats stood for, he paused a long, long time. And then finally he said--
共和党人似乎认同这些中产阶级的价值观。当我问他是否喜欢民主党支持的任何东西时，他停顿了很久很久。然后他终于说——
Well, what do they stand for? Women in the military. Gay rights.
嗯，他们支持什么？军队里的女性。同性恋权利。
It wasn't that he disagreed with them. It's that they seem to stand for nothing, which brings us to the topic at hand-- this week's Democratic National Convention. Delegates had been instructed that when they talked to the press, they were to talk about the three big themes-- three big themes, I should say, designed precisely to win over voters like Joe Cabazuela.
并不是说他不同意这些，而是他们似乎什么也不支持，这就引出了当下的主题——本周的民主党全国代表大会。代表们被告知，当他们与媒体交谈时，要谈论三个大主题——我应该说，这三个大主题是专门为争取像乔·卡巴祖埃拉这样的选民而设计的。
We have been told that we should be emphasizing the themes of opportunity, responsibility, and community.
我们被告知，我们应该强调机会、责任和社区这些主题。
But these themes are so vague. It's so vague. Anything could be community, opportunity, and responsibility. I mean, those could be the Republican themes.
但这些主题太模糊了。太模糊了。任何东西都可以是社区、机会和责任。我的意思是，那些本可以是共和党的主题。
That's true. That's true.
那是真的。那是真的。
In fact, this woman, Ruth Horowitz, told me that her delegation, which was from Vermont, had been playing this little game with the theme. The way that it worked is that you'd try to make up a sentence using all the three words, and then you'd try to work that sentence into everyday conversation.
事实上，这位名叫露丝·霍洛维茨的女士告诉我，她所在的代表团（来自佛蒙特州）一直在围绕这个主题玩一个小游戏。游戏的玩法是，你尝试造一个包含这三个词的句子，然后你尝试把那个句子用到日常对话中。
So for example, if you're getting into the cab, you say something like, I feel it's my responsibility as a member of this community to give you the opportunity to get in first.
举个例子，如果你要上一辆出租车，你会说：“作为这个社区的一员，我感到有责任让你先上车，这是你的机会。”
In a certain way, this was not that different from what people were trying to do in seriousness. Several people went through the motions for me of trying to express their beliefs in terms of the three big themes. But it always had the air of somebody fulfilling a ninth-grade essay topic. It never had the directness and conviction that the Republican delegates in San Diego had when they talked to me about their very concrete goals-- 50% tax cut, banning abortion, getting school vouchers, stuff like that. And it's hard to imagine Joe Cabazuela would have been satisfied with what he heard among the Democrats.
在某种程度上，这与人们试图认真做的事情并没有什么不同。几个人为我演示了如何用这三个大主题来表达他们的信仰。但它总有一种人在完成九年级作文题的感觉。它从未像圣迭戈的共和党代表们那样具有直接性和信念感，当时他们和我谈论的是他们非常具体的目标——削减50%的税收、禁止堕胎、获得学校代金券之类的东西。很难想象乔·卡巴祖埃拉会对他在民主党人那里听到的内容感到满意。
Well, I don't know if I can find a fancy way to say this, but from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, we bring you stories from a variety of writers and performers on some topic. In this hour, today, stories from the Democratic Convention you probably have not heard elsewhere, and how did the Democrats communicate what they stand for?
好吧，我不知道我是否能找到一种华丽的方式来说明这一点，但来自WBEZ芝加哥电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们都会为您带来来自不同作家和表演者关于某个主题的故事。在今天这一个小时里，我们将讲述您在别处可能没听说过的民主党大会的故事，以及民主党人是如何传达他们立场的信息的？
Act One, A Little Tour Inside the Message Machine. Act Two, the latest installment of Michael Lewis' Campaign Diaries. This week-- Michael makes Al Gore nervous. Act Three, this act, you may remember a bestselling book from a few years ago called There Are No Children Here by a writer named Alex Kotlowitz. There was a Oprah Winfrey movie of this. It was about two boys growing up in Chicago's Henry Horner public housing projects. Well, those projects are the projects that are directly across the street from the Democratic Convention. And one of the kids from that book, who's now grown up, gives us a tour. There's been some superficial cleaning up for the convention, you've probably heard, but there's a way more profound and interesting change going on in the neighborhood as well. Act Four, webmaster and Beverly Hills, 90201 expert, Danny Drennan on the convention, and more. Stay with us.
第一幕，消息机器内部的小游览。第二幕，迈克尔·刘易斯《竞选日记》的最新一期。本周——迈克尔让阿尔·戈尔感到紧张。第三幕，这一幕，你可能还记得几年前一本畅销书，由一位名叫亚历克斯·科特洛维茨的作家写的《这里没有孩子》。奥普拉·温弗瑞还拍过一部相关的电影。故事讲述了两个在芝加哥亨利·霍纳公共住房项目中长大的男孩。嗯，这些项目就在民主党大会会场的正对面。书中其中一个现在已经长大的孩子将带我们参观。你可能听说过，为了这次大会，这里进行了一些表面的清理工作，但这个社区也正在发生深刻而有趣的变化。第四幕，网站管理员和《飞越比弗利》专家丹尼·德南谈论大会及更多内容。请继续收听。
Act One. Two days before the Republican Convention started, security was already very tight. Two days before the Democratic Convention, it was still possible just to breeze into the hall, walk into all the hidden corridors, go straight to the makeup room, to the speech writers' room, to the sign rooms, which are basically these big freezers filled with pre-printed signs for the pre-planned floor demonstrations. They said stuff like "The Brady Bill," "10 Million New Jobs," "Protecting Education."
第一幕。共和党大会开始前两天，安全工作已经非常严密。民主党大会开始前两天，人们仍然可以轻易地溜进大厅，走进所有隐藏的走廊，直接去化妆室、演讲稿撰写室、标牌室，这些基本上是大冷库，里面装满了预先印好的标语，用于预先计划的地板示威活动。它们写着诸如“布雷迪法案”、“1000万个新工作岗位”、“保护教育”之类的内容。
Late Saturday night, senator Barbara Boxer came into the mostly empty hall with a few aides, just to check it out. The wall of TV screens that's behind the podium had no images on them before she stepped on the dais. And then, as if activated by the mere presence of a United States senator, they filled with heartwarming black-and-white images of everyday Americans. Most of the other people in the hall to witness this were balloon wranglers.
周六深夜，参议员芭芭拉·博克瑟和几名助手来到空荡荡的大厅，只是为了看看情况。在她踏上主席台之前，讲台后面的电视屏幕墙上没有显示任何图像。然后，就像被一位美国参议员的出现所激活一样，屏幕上充满了令人心动的、展现日常美国人的黑白图像。大厅里目睹这一幕的其他大多数人都是气球管理员。
One of the problems of trying to report on these conventions over a television and radio is that it's hard to convey the sheer size of what they're about, the hundreds of lavish parties each day, the millions of dollars of TV studios and offices bought and brought in just for this occasion, an Olympic village of these in trailers outside the hall, which all get torn down after four days. So to get a sense of the scale of this, let's just take one small aspect of it, and let's take the balloon drop. 150,000 balloons, in bags of 1,000 balloons each, they get hoisted slowly up to the ceiling of the United Center.
试图通过电视和广播报道这些大会的问题之一是，很难传达它们规模的宏大：每天举办的数百场奢华派对、为这次活动购买和带来的价值数百万美元的电视演播室和办公室，以及大厅外拖车里的奥林匹克村，所有这些在四天后都会被拆除。为了了解其规模，让我们取一个小方面，看看气球坠落仪式。15万个气球，装在每袋1000个气球的袋子里，被缓慢地吊到联合中心的天花板上。
This is the second biggest balloon drop ever, according to Tanzi Lewis, who's one of the minority contractors who got the contract to do the drop.
这是有史以来第二大气球坠落仪式，据承包此次坠落项目的少数族裔承包商之一坦齐·刘易斯说。
What's the next biggest job you've done to this job?
你做过的工作中，仅次于这次工作的下一大工作是什么？
To be honest, my largest odd-job was at the Taste of Chicago this summer.
老实说，我最大的零工是今年夏天的芝加哥品味节。
How many balloons was that?
那有多少个气球？
That consisted of only 1,000 balloons.
那只有1000个气球。
So that's just the number of balloons in one of these bags.
所以那只是这些袋子中其中一个的气球数量。
That's correct.
没错。
It took 150 people four days and nights to fill the balloons. They did it at Malcolm X College, which is just two blocks from the convention site. One can only imagine what Malcolm X would have said about all this. Upstairs in the school, "By Any Means Necessary" is painted on the wall. Downstairs, 150 people were filling balloons to celebrate Bill Clinton, loading those into huge nets, each 40 feet long.
150个人花了四个昼夜才把这些气球装满。他们是在马尔科姆·X学院做的，离会场只有两个街区。人们只能想象马尔科姆·X对这一切会说些什么。在学校楼上，墙上写着“不惜一切代价”。在楼下，150个人正在装气球来庆祝比尔·克林顿，把它们装进巨大的网兜里，每个都有40英尺长。
If you picture a bag that you could drive three pickup trucks into, you've pretty much got the idea of what one of these things look like. And 11 of them, filled with red, white, and blue balloons, lay on the floor of the gymnasium. The air was thick with the plastic, powdery smell of balloons. There's a sentence you don't get to say very often.
如果你想象一个可以开进三辆皮卡的袋子，你大概就能明白其中一个是什么样子了。11个装满红、白、蓝气球的网兜躺在体育馆的地板上。空气中弥漫着气球那种塑料、粉末的味道。这是一个你很少有机会说的句子。
Take, twist, turn, in the net. Take, twist, not in the net.
拿，扭，转，在网里。拿，扭，不在网里。
What is that, athletic tape around your fingers?
那是什么？你手指上的运动胶带吗？
Right, to keep it from burning, because after a while your fingers start to burn. You get, like, a blister.
是的，为了防止灼伤，因为过了一会儿你的手指就开始发烫。你会长出像水泡一样的东西。
Surprisingly, even here, in Democratic Chicago, in a roomful of people preparing a big party for Bill Clinton, people who don't even know if they're going to get paid for their work, feelings about the president were tepid.
令人惊讶的是，即使是在民主党的芝加哥，在一个为比尔·克林顿筹备盛大派对的人群中，甚至那些不知道自己工作是否能拿到报酬的人，对总统的感情也是冷淡的。
Now, are you a big President Clinton supporter?
那么，你是克林顿总统的忠实支持者吗？
No. I mean, I support him because he's the president, but I'm voting for Dole.
不。我的意思是，我支持他因为他是总统，但我打算投给多尔。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
How come?
为什么？
Because I am a born-again Christian, and I don't believe in abortion, and I don't believe in certain things that President Clinton is for. America is turning away from God. And so, therefore, the God is turning from America. And I really do. And that's why you're having high crime rates.
因为我是一名重生基督徒，我不相信堕胎，也不相信克林顿总统支持的某些事情。美国正在背离上帝。因此，上帝也在背离美国。我确实是这样认为的。这就是为什么你们会有高犯罪率。
Across the room, 11-year-old Jaris King and two other people hoist a 40-foot-long bag of balloons over their heads and carry it out into the hallway. And Jaris declares, to no one in particular--
在房间对面，11岁的贾里斯·金和其他两个人把一个40英尺长的气球袋举过头顶，抬到了走廊上。贾里斯不无感慨地说——
I feel like I'm a black smurf.
我觉得自己像个蓝精灵。
It does kind of look like a job for the smurfs. The balloons are carried down the hall, up a stairway, around a series of tight turns and doorways, out onto a loading dock, and over two blocks on Damen to the convention building, where they're checked by the Secret Service, and then lifted up to the ceiling.
看起来确实有点像蓝精灵的工作。气球沿着走廊被搬运，穿过楼梯，绕过一系列急转弯和门口，来到卸货平台，穿过达门街的两个街区，到达会议大楼，在那里它们接受特勤局的检查，然后被吊到天花板上。
There's three days of work for a few seconds of special effects. And it doesn't really make sense, but we gotta do it anyway.
三天的工作换来几秒钟的特效。这其实没多大意义，但我们还是得做。
Of course, there has to be a balloon drop. It's the kiss at the end of the wedding. It's the money shot.
当然，必须有气球坠落。这是婚礼结束时的接吻。这是高潮时刻。
Democrats all, delegates, alternates, friends, families, on to victory in '96, welcome to this issues forum, this overview.
民主党同仁们，代表们、候补代表们、朋友们、家人们，向96年的胜利进军，欢迎来到这次议题论坛，这次概述。
Monday morning, the hotel ballroom.
周一早上，酒店宴会厅。
We've got several speakers today describing what the winning strategy is for the Democrats, and to arm us so we go out for doing battle. I'm Heather Booth, the training director of the Democratic National Committee.
今天我们有几位演讲者来描述民主党的制胜策略，并武装我们去投入战斗。我是希瑟·布斯，民主党全国委员会的培训主任。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Every day, the DNC held these morning seminars. They combine practical information about campaign law, the latest talking points on issues, speakers, like campaign strategist James Carville, who used a mix of truths, half-truths, and, I have to say, real whoppers to inspire the party faithful.
民主党全国委员会每天都会举办这些早间研讨会。他们结合了关于竞选法律的实用信息、关于议题的最新谈话要点，以及像竞选策略家詹姆斯·卡维尔这样的演讲者，他混合了事实、半真半假的话，以及我不得不说，真正的弥天大谎来激励党的忠实支持者。
And I love when the Republicans and Bob Dole say, "Well, the teachers are all for the Democrats." OK, yeah, the teachers are for the Democrats. The tobacco companies are for the Republicans. Now, I got a question for ya. When your kids grows up, what would you rather do, be a teacher or smoke cigarettes?
我喜欢当共和党人和鲍勃·多尔说：“好吧，老师们都支持民主党。”好的，是的，老师们支持民主党。烟草公司支持共和党。现在，我有个问题要问你们。当你的孩子长大后，你宁愿他们做什么，当老师还是抽烟？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
In fact, the tobacco companies sponsor both political parties, and that support included sponsorship of a number of events at this very convention. After Carville, Congressman Steny Hoyer presented a series of charts and graphs on overhead slides to make the case for how the Democrats could take 20 new seats in the House of Representatives, which would give them the House majority, and knock Newt Gingrich out of the speaker's chair.
事实上，烟草公司赞助了这两个政党，这种支持包括对这次大会上的一些活动的赞助。卡维尔之后，国会议员斯滕尼·霍耶展示了一系列幻灯片上的图表和图形，以说明民主党如何能赢得众议院20个新席位，这将使他们获得众议院多数席位，并将纽特·金里奇赶下议长宝座。
Now, this is the important point, because I want all of you to believe, deeply ingrained, intellectually and emotionally, when you go back to your states, Hoyer was right, we can win back the House of Representatives. Republicans currently hold 28 seats that traditionally perform Democratically. These are Democratic seats. We oughta have 'em. Republicans hold 77 seats that Clinton won.
现在，这是一个重要点，因为我希望你们所有人都能深信不疑，在智力和情感上，当你们回到各自的州时，霍耶是对的，我们可以赢回众议院。共和党目前占据了28个传统上表现为民主党的席位。这些是民主党的席位。我们理应拥有它们。共和党占据了77个克林顿赢下的席位。
33 of these Republican seats belong to freshmen who came in with less than 55% of the vote. It was one chart after another, each with a climbing upward yellow arrow. When it came to the part of the presentation where Congressman Hoyer had to name actual races that were in the bag, he could only name five or six. If you ask nonpartisan experts who follow this kind of thing, like Charles Cook, who publishes a well-known Washington newsletter called Cook's Political Report , they put the Democrats' chances of taking back the House this way.
其中33个共和党席位属于得票率不到55%的新人。一张又一张的图表，每一张都有向上攀升的黄色箭头。当演示到国会议员霍耶必须点出确定能赢的比赛时，他只能点出五六个。如果你问像查尔斯·库克这样关注此类事情的无党派专家，他出版了一份名为《库克政治报告》的华盛顿著名通讯，他们是这样看待民主党夺回众议院的机会的。
I think Democrats have about a 30% or 40% chance of getting the House back, but that's down from about 50%, 40% or 50% maybe a month or so ago. One of the questions we're watching very carefully is something called the Generic Congressional Ballot test. It's when you ask, if the election were held today, would you vote for the Democratic candidate for Congress or Republican candidate? And we were seeing Democrats with a six-, seven-, even eight-point lead on a lot of polls late June, early July. And at that level, it was roughly a tidal wave of the magnitude that you saw Republicans win in 1994. Today, it's down at the two- or three-point range, which is right about at the edge of what they need to to get that House back.
我认为民主党夺回众议院的机会大约有30%或40%，但比起一个月前可能还有50%左右，下降了不少。我们密切关注的问题之一叫做“通用国会选票测试”。也就是问：如果今天举行选举，你会投票给民主党的国会候选人还是共和党的候选人？在六月下旬、七月初的许多民调中，我们看到民主党有六、七甚至八个百分点的领先优势。在那个水平上，它几乎像你在1994年共和党获胜时看到的那种潮汐。今天，它下降到了二或三个百分点的范围，这正好处于他们夺回众议院所需边缘的边缘。
Interestingly, Mr. Cook was one of the experts Congressman Hoyer cited, but when Congressman Hoyer quoted him, it was to support the case that a Democratic sweep was imminent.
有趣的是，库克先生是国会议员霍耶引用的专家之一，但当国会议员霍耶引用他时，却是为了支持民主党即将大获全胜的说法。
In the convention hall, the rule of thumb is that the fewer colorful buttons someone wears, the more important they are. You probably also didn't see this at home-- but does everybody know this-- periodically throughout the convention, everyone on the floor would stop the business of politics and just do the Macarena. It happened over and over. The Macarena is the official song of the Democratic National Convention.
在大会会场，经验法则是佩戴的彩色徽章越少，地位就越重要。你可能在家里也没看到——但大家都知道吗——在整个大会期间，地板上的每个人都会时不时停止政治事务，跳起马卡雷纳舞。这发生了一次又一次。马卡雷纳舞是民主党全国代表大会的正式歌曲。
A political convention like this essentially has to solve a theatrical problem, how to take an ordinary person and make him seem larger than life. And that problem is compounded in the age of television, because who could we possibly know more intimately then we know Bill Clinton. He's in our homes every day on television. We've heard about his sex life. We've heard about his finances. We've heard about his bad investments. We know his ideas. We know what he eats. We know what the man wears jogging.
像这样的政治大会本质上必须解决一个戏剧性问题，如何把一个普通人塑造得比生命本身更伟大。而在电视时代，这个问题变得更加复杂，因为还有谁比我们更了解比尔·克林顿呢？他每天都在电视上出现在我们的家里。我们听过他的性生活。我们听过他的财务状况。我们听过他的糟糕投资。我们知道他的想法。我们知道他吃什么。我们知道他在慢跑时穿什么。
I mean, do you know what your friends wear jogging? Justin Hayford attended the Convention for American Theater. And he said to make him seem larger than life in this setting, they used one of the oldest tricks in the book, and that is the long, slow arrival. You know, where the person's constantly being announced. We're constantly hearing word of the great man's imminent arrival. And of course, there was the train trip, the 1,800-mile mile train trip.
我的意思是，你知道你的朋友慢跑时穿什么吗？贾斯汀·海福德参加了美国剧院的代表大会。他说，为了让他在这个环境中显得比生命更伟大，他们使用了书中历史最悠久的技巧之一，那就是漫长而缓慢的到达。你知道，那个人不断地被宣布（出场）。我们不断听到那位伟人即将到达的消息。当然，还有火车旅行，1800英里的火车旅行。
That's gorgeous, because the most postmodern element about this convention is the performance of absence, that they are working extremely hard to make his absence a sort of ache, a longing for this man. And so, from the very first day, there are train updates. I don't know if these ended up on television or not, but there are train updates where they cut away on the large video screen to a little schematic map of his 1,800-mile train route, going through the Heartland, of course. And they would say, and here's a live shot of his train pulling into Lindley, Ohio or somewhere.
那真是太棒了，因为这次大会最后现代的元素是关于“缺席的表演”，他们正在极力使他的缺席成为一种痛苦，一种对这个人的渴望。因此，从第一天开始，就有火车更新。我不知道这些最终是否上了电视，但确实有火车更新，他们在大屏幕上切换到一个关于他1800英里火车路线的小示意图，当然是穿过腹地。他们会说，这是他的火车开进俄亥俄州林德利或某个地方的现场画面。
And you see a train going by. And people cheer as though they haven't seen a train before. And so he's getting closer and closer, and the gospel choir comes out and they sing, "If you want him, if you need him, if you adore him, shout yes." And they never mention who him is, so one must assume it's the president. So we're following his progress. I thought he was going to sail across the lake, is what I had heard, which I thought was a sort of beautiful, Cleopatraesque move, like coming in on a great golden barge, but he didn't. He came in by helicopter, which is quite an entrance.
然后你看到一列火车经过。人们欢呼，好像他们以前没见过火车一样。于是他越来越近，唱诗班出来唱道：“如果你想要他，如果你需要他，如果你崇拜他，大声喊出来。”他们从来没提“他”是谁，所以人们只能认为这是总统。所以我们关注着他的进度。我听说他要横渡湖泊，这是我听到的，我觉得这是一种很美的、像克利奥帕特拉那样的举动，就像乘着一艘宏伟的金色驳船进来，但他没有。他是乘直升机进来的，这真是个了不起的入场方式。
And then Daley said, "Mr. President, we've waited four days to see you." Which I thought was the ultimate capper to that entrance, which is, we're dying for your presence, we are dying to eat you with our eyes, as though we haven't for the last four years. Every intimate detail of his life, we've seen.
然后戴利说：“总统先生，我们等了你四天了。”我觉得这是那个入场方式的终极补充，意思是，我们渴望你的出现，我们渴望用眼睛把你吃掉，好像我们过去四年没看过一样。他生活的每一个亲密细节，我们都见过。
So in the hall, did this create an aching desire to see the president? Well, Justin Hayford says that on the first day, with the first train update--
那么在大厅里，这是否创造了一种想见到总统的痛苦渴望？嗯，贾斯汀·海福德说在第一天，随着第一次火车更新——
People screamed like it was David Bowie or something. And yesterday, I was there in the afternoon, and they did the same thing. It was the newest train update, and nobody paid any attention to it.
人们尖叫得好像那是大卫·鲍伊一样。昨天，我下午在那里，他们做了同样的事情。那是最新的火车更新，但没人注意它。
Of course, he says, when Bill Clinton finally did appear in person, by that point, he had appeared so many times in the hall on video, that there was something kind of thrilling to see him in person. You know, you're so used to him on television,. And in the age of television, that is the rarest thing of all, to see the man live. And the theater of it is really hard to beat.
当然，他说，当比尔·克林顿最终亲自出现时，在那之前，他在大厅的视频里出现过太多次了，所以亲自见到他有一种令人兴奋的感觉。你知道，你太习惯电视上的他了。在电视时代，那是所有事情中最罕见的，亲眼见到真人。而它的戏剧性真的很难被超越。
[SINGING] You are so nice to me. You are on my side. You are the man with the Midas touch. You are on my side with the Midas touch. Bill Clinton, Bill Clinton, Bill Clinton, Bill Clinton. You are the man who has the plans. You have the ability to put people to work. You are the President of the United States.
[歌唱] 你对我真好。你站在我这边。你是拥有迈达斯之手的人。你用迈达斯之手站在我这边。比尔·克林顿，比尔·克林顿，比尔·克林顿，比尔·克林顿。你是那个有计划的人。你有能力让人们工作。你是美利坚合众国的总统。
I'm just going to stop the song right there. That is my favorite line in this song, and maybe in almost any song. OK, here's your writing assignment. You want to write a song about the president. This, by the way, is Wesley Willis, a local Chicago artist. So what are you go to say? Well, you know, you can kind of run out of things of inspiration, so then you can just going into just straight factual mode. You are the President of the United States.
我就在这里停止这首歌。这是我在这首歌中最喜欢的一句，可能也是在几乎任何歌曲中最喜欢的一句。好了，这是你的写作作业。你想写一首歌关于总统。顺便说一句，这是卫斯理·威利斯，一位芝加哥当地艺术家。所以你要说什么？好吧，你知道，你可能会用尽灵感，所以你就可以直接进入单纯的事实模式。你是美利坚合众国的总统。
[SINGING] You are the man who has the plans. You have the ability to put people to work. You are the President of the United States. I like you a lot and I will award you. Bill Clinton, Bill Clinton, Bill Clinton, Bill Clinton.
[歌唱] 你是那个有计划的人。你有能力让人们工作。你是美利坚合众国的总统。我很喜欢你，我会给你颁奖。比尔·克林顿，比尔·克林顿，比尔·克林顿，比尔·克林顿。
Act Two, No Show. 15,000 members of the press were here in Chicago for the convention. And, well, you probably have guessed that political conventions are a big reunion for party regulars of the two major political parties. And unless you think about it, you might not realize that, for many reporters, it's also a big reunion. I saw people at the convention who I have not seen in years. And that was true in San Diego as well.
第二幕，缺席。15000名媒体成员来到芝加哥参加大会。嗯，你可能已经猜到了，政治大会是两个主要政党的常规成员的一次大聚会。除非你细想，否则你可能不会意识到，对于许多记者来说，这也是一次大聚会。我在大会上看到了几年没见的人。在圣迭戈也是如此。
So what do people talk about at these very high-powered media events? Well, as far as I can tell, it's a little politics, a lot of gossip. And then, the other night, I was with some friends visiting from New York City to cover the convention, and my friends from New York got into this conversation that was so strange to me that, at some point, I pulled out my tape recorder and just started taping them.
那么人们在这些高权力的媒体活动中谈论什么呢？嗯，据我所知，是一些政治，很多八卦。然后，那天晚上，我和一些从纽约市赶来报道大会的朋友在一起，我那些来自纽约的朋友陷入了一场对我来说如此奇怪的谈话，以至于在某个时候，我拿出了我的录音机，开始录下他们的话。
The conversation was about The New York Times . And it began when one of the New Yorkers said, with pleasure, with a kind of intense pleasure, actually, that the Times arrives at 7:00 in the morning at the hotel. She sort of announced this. At home, she gets the Times at 5:30, which is better, of course, but 7:00 was still just very, very good, above the sort of standard that they were all used to when they travel around in hotels.
谈话是关于《纽约时报》的。它开始于其中一位纽约人带着愉悦，实际上是一种强烈的愉悦，宣布《泰晤士报》在早上7点准时送达酒店。她在家里，早上5:30就能收到《泰晤士报》，当然那更好，但7点依然非常非常好，高于他们所有人出差住酒店时习惯的标准。
Then all the New York media people started quizzing each other about The New York Times at length, in minute detail. Chess columnists who'd gone on to other beats, and people who had moved to Atlanta and from Atlanta, people who I have never even heard of.
然后所有的纽约媒体人开始详细地、细致地互相考问关于《纽约时报》的内容。转去其他版块的国际象棋专栏作家，搬到亚特兰大又从亚特兰大搬回来的人，我甚至从来没听说过的人。
Who does his main beat is basically, like, feelings and psychology.
他的主要任务基本上是关于情感和心理。
Oh, Gorman.
哦，戈尔曼。
Yeah. Wow, I thought--
是的。哇，我以为——
Do you know Gorman?
你认识戈尔曼吗？
--that it'd be harder. Who's the doctor columnist? Medical?
——那会更难。那个医生专栏作家是谁？医学的？
Ah, what's his name? Altman.
啊，他叫什么来着？奥特曼。
Who sometimes uses MD and then sometimes doesn't.
他有时用医学博士头衔，有时又不用。
My more or less atheist friends from the liberal, elite media have the same relationship to The New York Times that certain Catholics have with the Vatican. The Times speaks definitively. They kneel before it. They quibble with it. They sneer. I have to say, this was the most animated conversation they had all night, and it lasted, like half an hour. I mean, at some point, I just had to say good night. They could've kept going.
我那些或多或少是无神论的自由派精英媒体朋友，对《纽约时报》的关系就像某些天主教徒对梵蒂冈的关系一样。《泰晤士报》的说法是权威的。他们跪在它面前。他们对它吹毛求疵。他们冷嘲热讽。我不得不说，这是他们整晚最活跃的谈话，持续了大约半小时。我的意思是，在某个时候，我不得不说晚安。他们本可以一直谈下去。
OK, now, Steven I know knows this, so I'll just post it to the rest of you. Who is most likely, if it's discovered that there is or is not a god, who is most likely to have the story?
好了，现在，我知道史蒂文知道这个，所以我只问你们其他人。如果发现有上帝或没有上帝，谁最有可能掌握这个独家报道？
Rosenthal.
罗森塔尔。
No, there is one reporter who is the existential reporter for the Times.
不，有一位记者是《泰晤士报》的存在主义记者。
There you have it, life in the fast lane. Overpriced drinks came from the hotel bar, went quickly onto some TV network's charge card. Well, one reporter who was here with the 15,000 was Michael Lewis, who has been publishing his Campaign Diaries in The New Republic . I'm reading them from time to time on our very program. He's new to this whole pack journalism thing, and to political conventions. And here's the latest installment from his Campaign Diaries.
正如你所见，这就是快车道上的生活。过高价的饮料来自酒店酒吧，很快就记在了某个电视网的信用卡上。嗯，和这15000人一起在这里的记者之一是迈克尔·刘易斯，他一直在《新共和》杂志上发表他的《竞选日记》。我不时在我们的节目中读它们。他是这种集群新闻报道方式和政治大会的新手。这是他《竞选日记》的最新一期。
August the 19th, one moment I'm sleeping soundly in my hotel room in San Diego, the next the phone is ringing and a voice on the other end of the line is asking, "This is the Vice President's office, can you take the call?" Al Gore himself is on the line. In a moment of weakness, thinking that maybe I should interview someone important, I had sent a message to Gore's office saying that I wanted to speak with him. I hardly expected him to take it seriously.
8月19日，前一刻我还睡在圣迭戈的酒店房间里，下一刻电话就响了，电话那头有个声音在问：“这是副总统办公室，你能接电话吗？”阿尔·戈尔本人在通话。在虚弱的时刻，心想也许我应该采访一些重要人物，我发了一条消息给戈尔的办公室，说我想和他谈谈。我几乎没指望他会认真对待。
"It's nerve-racking getting a call from the Vice President," I say, pretending to be wide awake. Gore chuckles unhappily. I've made him uncomfortable. "No, seriously," I say. "This is the highest I've climbed in the world." This merely makes things worse. "I don't believe that at all," he says nervously, attempting to maneuver me back into some acceptable mode of political discourse. "I have only five minutes to interview. Two of them are now gone."
“接到副总统的电话真是伤脑筋，”我说，装作完全清醒。戈尔不高兴地轻笑。我让他感到不舒服了。“不，说真的，”我说。“这是我在这个世界上攀爬到的最高位置。”这只会让事情变得更糟。“我一点也不相信那个，”他紧张地说，试图把我拉回到某种可接受的政治话语模式。“我只有五分钟时间采访。现在已经过去两分钟了。”
Well, I'm sort of curious to know if Gore's environmentalism, as it appears, has vanished down the sinkhole of practical politics. But the Vice President's conversation is littered with "franklies," and "to be honest with you's," and "it is my understanding's," all of which translates into civilian English as, I'm never going to tell you the truth about anything, so why on earth are you asking?
嗯，我有点好奇戈尔的环保主义，就像看起来的那样，是否已经消失在实用政治的下水道里了。但副总统的谈话中充斥着“坦率地说”、“老实告诉你”和“据我所知”，所有这些在平民英语中翻译过来就是：我永远不会告诉你关于任何事情的真相，那你到底为什么要问？
Before he hangs up, Gore tells me that, A, Americans truly are committed to nature, B, that he's not more intimidated having to debate Jack Kemp than having to debate, say, Connie Mack, and C, that the collection of speeches written by White House speech writers and now published as a book by Bill Clinton was penned entirely by Clinton himself. It is his understanding, Gore says.
在他挂断电话之前，戈尔告诉我，A，美国人确实致力于自然保护；B，面对杰克·肯普辩论并不比面对，比方说，康妮·麦克更有压力；C，由白宫演讲稿撰写人编写并现在由比尔·克林顿出版的一本书中，演讲集完全是由克林顿本人撰写的。戈尔说，据他所知。
August the 26th and 27th. Your first day at a convention is like your first day at school. Upon seeing the hordes, your first instinct is that something important is happening, that everyone must know something you don't. For a few hours, I'm engaged in a wild, undignified scramble to find out what that something is. During this uncomfortable period, all sorts of information lands on my lap-- a stack of old articles from Chicago Magazine, drafts of speeches by retired congressmen, lists of delegates, stuff no one in his right mind would read. But nothing can be ignored. I even interview a delegate.
8月26日和27日。你在大会的第一天就像你在学校的第一天。看到人山人海，你的第一本能是觉得发生了重要的事情，每个人肯定都知道一些你不知道的事情。几个小时里，我一直在疯狂、毫无尊严地忙碌，想找出那是什么。在这个不舒服的时期，各种各样的信息落到我手里——一堆《芝加哥杂志》的旧文章、退休国会议员的演讲草稿、代表名单，那些神志正常的人绝不会读的东西。但什么都不能忽视。我甚至采访了一位代表。
But then there is this tremendous noise on one side of the convention hall, a spontaneous outbreak of whistles and cheers that draws all the attention to the entrance beneath the Nevada delegation. The sound is exactly what you would expect if a billionaire was handing out sacks of cash, of if a woman were performing a striptease. Here, I think, is clearly where the action is. I plow through the crowd to find out what it is. It is Al Gore.
但随后在会场的一侧传来一阵巨大的噪音，一阵自发的口哨声和欢呼声，吸引了所有人的注意，看向内华达代表团下方的入口。那声音正是你预期的，如果一个亿万富翁在散发成袋的现金，或者如果一个女人在表演脱衣舞。我想，这里显然就是行动的核心。我挤过人群去找出那是什么。是阿尔·戈尔。
A normal person might well wonder what 15,000 journalists are doing covering an event of dubious importance. It's not an easy question to answer. The journalists who write about other journalists, like Howie Kurtz of the Washington Post , write about the futility of being a journalist at the Democratic Convention. The Post , I'm told, has sent the same number of people here as they have in all their foreign bureaus combined. The famous journalists invert their occupation and give interviews to other journalists. The rest of us are resigned to finding some nugget slightly different from the nuggets of others.
一个正常人可能会很好奇，15000名记者在一个意义不明的事件中进行报道是在做什么。这不是一个容易回答的问题。那些报道其他记者的记者，比如《华盛顿邮报》的豪伊·库尔茨，写道在民主党大会上当记者的徒劳无功。《华盛顿邮报》被告知，派到这里的人数与他们所有外国分社的总和一样多。著名的记者颠覆了他们的职业，接受其他记者的采访。我们其他人只能无奈地寻找一些与其他记者的金块略有不同的金块。
It turns out few of the journalists actually attend the convention, except during prime time. The journalists remain in their tents outside the United Center. In the first two days, between 3:30 in the afternoon and 7:00 at night, maybe a few dozen people pass through the section of the hall reserved for the periodical press. This is a shame, because the best time to be in the hall is when no one is paying much attention.
事实证明，除了黄金时段，很少有记者真正参加大会。记者们留在联合中心外面的帐篷里。在前两天，下午3:30到晚上7:00之间，也许只有几十个人经过为期刊新闻预留的大厅区域。这很遗憾，因为在大厅里最好的时间是没人关注的时候。
For example, Hillary Clinton pops in mid-afternoon to check the mic levels and the height of her podium. She steps up in her pink suit, and when she sees that the podium is too high, kicks off her pink heels. She stands there girlishly in her stockinged feet, asking too many questions of the men around here. And you can see that, like everyone else who plays her adamantine role, she is far more vulnerable than she lets on. Later I hear from one of her speech writers that she's as nervous as she looks. It's her first speech in prime time.
例如，希拉里·克林顿在下午中途出现检查麦克风水平和讲台的高度。她穿着粉色套装走上台，当她看到讲台太高时，踢掉了她的粉色高跟鞋。她在那儿像小女孩一样站在袜子里，问周围的男人们太多的问题。你可以看出，像所有玩弄她那坚如磐石的角色的人一样，她远比她表现出来的更脆弱。后来我从她的一位演讲稿撰写人那里听说，她和看起来一样紧张。这是她在黄金时段的第一次演讲。
Even after the convention begins, no one pays it much heed. And so, when Dick Gephardt speaks, I'm able to crawl right up behind him on the platform and see what life looks like from the speaker's point of view. Essentially, life looks predetermined. The speaker stares into four teleprompters, one at his left shoulder, another at his right shoulder, a third mounted straight ahead of him across the hall just beneath the cameras, so that he can appear to be looking at you when you're watching him on TV. The fourth is embedded into the podium, just above his navel.
即使在大会开始后，也没人注意它。所以，当迪克·格普哈特演讲时，我得以爬到他身后的平台上，看看站在演讲者的角度生活是什么样子的。本质上，生活看起来是预先决定的。演讲者盯着四个提词器，一个在他左肩，一个在他右肩，第三个安装在他正前方的大厅对面摄像机下方，这样当你在电视上看着他时，他看起来就像在看着你。第四个嵌入讲台中，就在他的肚脐上方。
Gephardt's speech, in letters four inches high, like the text of a book for the elderly, scrolls gently across. Gephardt has only to swivel back and forth between the teleprompters and pretend not to be reading word for word, which he is. "We meet here to offer a vision, not just a show for television," he is saying. No wonder no one listens. Part of the thrill of watching a public speaker lies in the risk the speaker takes in putting himself before you.
格普哈特的演讲，用四英寸高的字母，像给老年人的书本文字一样，缓缓滚动。格普哈特只需要在提词器之间来回转动，假装不是在逐字逐句阅读，而他确实在读。“我们在这里相聚，是为了提供一个愿景，而不仅仅是一场电视秀，”他说。难怪没人听。观看公众演讲者的快感部分在于演讲者把自己放在你面前所冒的风险。
Jesse Jackson, for one, understands this. In the first two days, he alone shuts down the teleprompters and speaks from loose notes. And he alone fully engages the crowd. Interestingly, the moment he first brings the crowd to its feet is just the moment that he leaves his notes.
杰西·杰克逊就是一个理解这一点的人。在前两天，只有他关掉了提词器，用简短的笔记演讲。只有他完全吸引了人群。有趣的是，他第一次让观众起立的时刻，正是他放下笔记的时刻。
But Jackson is the exception. The average convention speech arises not out of the need of the speaker to say something important, but out of the speaker's desire to have delivered a speech at the convention. Its purpose, from the speaker's point of view, is to establish his position in the official structure of the Democratic Party. The big exception are the speeches designed to make people cry-- Ron Brown's widow, Jim Brady's wife, and Christopher Reeve are, of course, well-known victims. The speeches delivered by relative unknowns in the wee hours of the afternoon contain wagon-loads more of the same bathos.
但杰克逊是个例外。普通的大会演讲并非出于演讲者有话要说的需要，而是出于演讲者希望在大会上发表演讲的欲望。从演讲者的角度来看，它的目的是建立他在民主党官方结构中的地位。大的例外是那些旨在让人流泪的演讲——罗恩·布朗的遗孀、吉姆·布雷迪的妻子和克里斯托弗·里夫当然是著名的受害者。在下午深夜时分由相对不知名的人发表的演讲包含了更多同样的伤感。
Here is a representative sample of opening lines, snatched in a single pass at the press table. "As the father of a child brutally murdered by a habitual violent criminal--" "As many of you know, my husband was a former tobacco lobbyist who died this past March." "December 7, 1993, that was the day a man with a semiautomatic weapon boarded the train. My husband was one of those killed."
这是开场白的代表性样本，在新闻台随意抓取的一个段子。“作为一名被惯常暴力罪犯残忍谋杀的孩子的父亲——”“正如你们许多人所知，我的丈夫曾是一名烟草说客，今年3月去世了。”“1993年12月7日，那天一个携带半自动武器的男人登上了火车。我的丈夫是遇难者之一。”
By early in the second day, you can see that people's capacity to absorb bad news has dwindled to nothing. A pleasant middle-aged woman describes the recent death of her husband from lung cancer, for instance, and no one in the hall pays her any mind. It is an incongruous sight, a woman in bright yellow, on the verge of tears as she relates her tragic loss, over a loud hum from the audience below, most of which is engrossed in small talk and hot dogs.
第二天一早，你可以看出人们吸收坏消息的能力已经降到了零。一位愉快的中年妇女描述了她丈夫最近因肺癌去世的情况，例如，大厅里没人理会她。这是一个不和谐的景象，一个穿着亮黄色衣服的女人，在讲述她悲惨损失时几近落泪，而下面观众席传来巨大的嗡嗡声，其中大部分人正沉浸在闲聊和热狗中。
Raising my binoculars-- necessary equipment here-- from the floor to the ceiling, I can't help but notice something. The higher you get, the whiter the people get. Almost all of the black people are on the floor. The faces in the sky boxes are lily white. A nugget!
举起双筒望远镜——这里必备的设备——从地板到天花板，我禁不住注意到一件事。你爬得越高，人就越白。几乎所有的黑人都在地板上。天空包厢里的脸白得像百合花。一个金块！
At the end of the first evening, I make my way up to the sky boxes. The sky boxes at the convention, it turns out, are much like the sky boxes at the Bulls games. They've been reserved for the rich people and their companies who can afford to pay for them. These include some of the 72 corporate CEOs, many of them Republicans, who coughed up $100,000 each to be honorary vice chairmen of the Democratic Convention.
第一天晚上结束时，我走到天空包厢。事实证明，大会上的天空包厢和公牛队比赛的天空包厢很像。它们是为那些付得起钱的有钱人和他们的公司预留的。其中包括72名企业首席执行官，其中许多是共和党人，他们每人支付了10万美元成为民主党大会的荣誉副主席。
Here is where you see curtained-off rooms decorated with signs that say "The Democratic Party would like to thank especially the Chicago Board Options Exchange and Patton Boggs LLB." Here is where you can find the people on whom the politicians focus their private attention. These people sit sipping red wine and nibbling on goodies, looking down upon the politicians, who tomorrow will have no choice but to take their phone calls.
在这里，你可以看到拉着窗帘的房间，上面装饰着写着“民主党特别感谢芝加哥期权交易所和巴顿·博格斯律师事务所”的标语。在这里，你可以找到政治家们私下关注的人。这些人坐着品尝红酒，吃着零食，俯视着那些政治家，而那些政治家明天将别无选择，只能接听他们的电话。
It's the end of the first night and pretty much everyone has left. But inside one of the many suites toils a middle-aged woman in a black-and-white penguin suit. For maybe half an hour, the woman works alone, tossing out open but untouched bottles of wine, and dumping large silver trays of food into giant green trash bags. The food tumbles into the bag in mouth-watering heaps. Chicken and beef satay, fried potato puffballs, shrimp remoulade, thinly sliced meats rolled up like oriental carpets.
那是第一天晚上的结束，几乎所有人都走了。但在许多套房中的一个里面，一个穿着黑白企鹅套装的中年妇女在工作。大约半小时，那个女人独自一人工作，把打开但未动的红酒瓶扔掉，把大银盘里的食物倒入巨大的绿色垃圾袋。食物成堆地掉进袋子里，令人垂涎欲滴。鸡肉和牛肉沙爹、炸土豆泡芙、虾仁冷盘、像东方地毯一样卷起来的薄片肉。
I'm curious what the woman is being paid to chuck out thousands of dollars of untouched food, but ask instead more generally about salaries at the United Center. "You mean what do I make?" she asks cheerfully as she empties a cow's worth of beef satay into the garbage. "$4 an hour." "This was one of the rooms reserved for the White House staff," the woman says idly. "They never came. They never called to cancel."
我很好奇那个女人拿多少钱去扔掉成千上万没动过的食物，但转而问得更笼统一些关于联合中心的薪水。“你是说我赚多少钱？”她一边把一头牛价值的牛肉沙爹倒进垃圾桶，一边愉快地问。“每小时4美元。”“这是留给白宫工作人员的房间之一，”女人漫不经心地说。“他们从来没来。他们从来没打电话取消。”
That's when you know you've arrive in the Democratic Party, I think, when you don't even care to use your reserved suite. When I watched George Stephanopoulos in the Chicago Health Club earlier today, reading the newspaper as the convention unfolded on the TV above his head, I didn't appreciate what I was seeing. The coolest thing to be at the Democratic Convention is a no-show.
我认为，当你甚至不在乎使用你预留的套房时，你就知道你已经进入了民主党。当今天早些时候我在芝加哥健身俱乐部看到乔治·斯蒂芬诺普洛斯，看着上面的电视上大会展开时读着报纸，我不明白我看到了什么。在民主党大会上最酷的事情就是当个“没来的人”。
Michael Lewis' Campaign Diaries appear in The New Republic . Coming up, Michael Lewis lets us listen in on a private conversation he has with President Clinton, and read some advanced copies of Hillary Clinton's speeches. Actually, he just talks to us about Dick Martin. Dick Morris. Dick Martin! He talks to us about Dick Martin. He talks to us about Dick Morris. Anyway, that's coming up in a minute, when our program continues.
迈克尔·刘易斯的《竞选日记》出现在《新共和》杂志上。接下来，迈克尔·刘易斯让我们听听他与克林顿总统的私人谈话，并阅读希拉里·克林顿演讲的一些预稿。实际上，他只是和我们谈论迪克·马丁。迪克·莫里斯。迪克·马丁！他跟我们谈论迪克·马丁。他跟我们谈论迪克·莫里斯。不管怎样，那一会儿就来，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, on our program, of course, we choose a topic and bring you documentary stories, radio monologues, reportage, found tapes, anything we can think of. Our subject today is the Democratic Convention that has been happening right here in our own backyard in Chicago, which is where we broadcast from.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题并带给您纪录片故事、电台独白、报道、发现的磁带，任何我们能想到的。我们今天的主题是民主党大会，它就在我们的后院芝加哥发生，我们也是从这里广播的。
So Michael Lewis wrote those diary entries that you just heard. And then, on the last day of the convention, when he came into our studio to record them, the news had broken that campaign strategist Dick Morris, the strategist who pushed the president to embrace family values, had let a prostitute listen in on phone conversations he had with the president and looked at the first lady's convention speech. Michael had not written about this yet, but he had thoughts about it.
所以迈克尔·刘易斯写了你们刚才听到的那些日记条目。然后，在大会的最后一天，当他来到我们的工作室录制它们时，新闻爆出说竞选策略家迪克·莫里斯，那位推动总统拥抱家庭价值观的策略家，曾让一名妓女旁听了他与总统的电话对话，并查看了第一夫人在大会上的演讲稿。迈克尔还没写到这个，但他对此有想法。
Your first emotional reaction to the news about Dick Morris was--
你对迪克·莫里斯新闻的第一情绪反应是——
Glee. I was very happy. And I guess I shouldn't have been, right? Because it's a very sad thing that happens to someone, a family man caught with a prostitute. And I'm not quite sure why I felt such glee. But I'm still very happy, as you can see. I think what it is is that I've been covering this process for now six months, and the serious political people-- Dole and Clinton, anyway-- present this sort of slick facade that's entirely phony, so that whenever anything like this that's seemingly authentic happens, it comes as an enormous relief, some little glimpse of reality.
幸灾乐祸。我很高兴。我想我不应该这样，对吧？因为有人被妓女抓到是一件非常悲伤的事情，一个有家庭的人。我不太确定为什么我有这种幸灾乐祸的感觉。但我仍然很高兴，如你所见。我想是因为我已经报道这个过程六个月了，严肃的政治人物——多尔和克林顿，无论如何——展现出这种完全虚假的圆滑外表，所以每当任何像这样看似真实的事情发生时，它就像是一种巨大的解脱，某种对现实的微小一瞥。
And you feel like their best-laid plans have been completely shattered by their advisor's desire to get laid. You can't help but dwell on it. I mean, compare that one incident to the entire Democratic Convention, and which is more interesting? Which will people talk about? It's no question, people are going to talk about Dick Morris and the prostitute.
你会觉得他们最完美的计划被他们顾问想睡觉的欲望完全打碎了。你禁不住去想它。我的意思是，将那一次事件与整个民主党大会相比较，哪个更有趣？人们会谈论哪个？毫无疑问，人们会谈论迪克·莫里斯和那个妓女。
And what could they have been talking about at the convention or in their campaigns that would have provided a counter?
他们在大会上或竞选中可以谈论什么能提供反驳吗？
Well, I just imagine if it had been a different time, or a time when the major parties were seriously grappling with major social problems, if someone was talking about, I don't know, things like the maldistribution of wealth, or the need for universal health care, or big social problems and addressing them in an interesting way, there'd be at least some counterweight to this. There'd be something else you want to talk about. There's nothing that's been said at the Democratic Convention that you care to dwell on.
好吧，我只是想象如果是在不同的时间，或者主要政党正在认真处理重大社会问题的时间，如果有人在谈论，我不知道，像财富分配不均、或全民医保的需求、或重大社会问题并以有趣的方式解决它们，至少会有一种反作用力。会有其他你想谈论的东西。在民主党大会上没有任何话是你愿意深究的。
Right. Instead, in the Democratic Convention, it's all just, let's not get kids to smoke.
对。相反，在民主党大会上，一切都只是，别让孩子们抽烟。
Right. It's a parade of unobjectionable sentiment.
对。这是一场不可反驳情绪的游行。
And small issues rather than big ones.
而且是小议题，而不是大议题。
Right. Let's not frighten people, let's just-- it's just kind of, I don't know, low-level niceness, which I find really unpleasant.
对。别吓着人们，我们只是——这是一种，我不知道，低水平的亲切，我觉得这真的很不愉快。
It's interesting comparing it to '92, because remember in '92 when the Gennifer Flowers story came out, one of the spins that was put on it, I remember, was precisely James Carville saying, look, you can talk about the sex stuff all you want, but what we're talking about is national health care. That's what we're talking about.
和92年相比很有趣，因为记得92年当珍妮弗·弗劳尔斯的故事出来时，我记得有一种说法，正是詹姆斯·卡维尔说的，看，你可以谈论那些性事，但我们要谈论的是全民医保。我们要谈论的就是这个。
And it worked. I mean, people are interested in big issues. And if you confront the society head on and talk to it directly about things that concern it deeply, people won't be that distracted by the other things. I mean, you can see kind of a maturation in the electorate with regard to peccadilloes that-- I think there are all sorts of reasons for this. But Bill Clinton has been a great educator-- that we don't need our politicians to be saints.
而且奏效了。我的意思是，人们对重大议题感兴趣。如果你直接面对社会，直接和它谈论它深切关注的事情，人们就不会被其他事情分散注意力。我的意思是，你可以看到选民在面对“小瑕疵”时的一种成熟，关于这一点——我认为有很多原因。但比尔·克林顿是一位伟大的教育家——我们不需要我们的政治家是圣人。
Are you sort of surprised what you found once you went out and followed the campaigns around as much as you have?
你是否对你出去跟踪竞选活动后发现的东西感到惊讶？
Well, you know, I've always thought of myself as a good Democrat. It's probably more true to say that it was a good liberal. But I'm having this very weird experience in covering the campaign, actually getting close to politics, which I've never really done until six months ago. I think I know now what it feels like to be an adolescent boy who discovers that he's more sexually attracted to boys than to girls. That I'm discovering, here I've gotten into this process thinking I'm a Democrat, and I'm discovering that I'm more attracted to Republicans than to Democrats, thinking maybe I'm a Republican. So I'm just sorting this out, why I have these feelings. And maybe a few months of therapy and some discussion with friendly Democrats, maybe I'll come around.
嗯，你知道，我一直认为自己是个好民主党人。说是一个好的自由派可能更准确。但在报道竞选活动的过程中，我有一种非常奇怪的经历，实际上是在接近政治，我在六个月前从未真正这样做过。我想我现在知道作为一个发现自己对男孩比对女孩更性吸引的青春期男孩是什么感觉了。我发现，我带着以为自己是民主党人的想法进入这个过程，而我发现我对共和党人比对民主党人更感兴趣，想着也许我是个共和党人。所以我正在理清这一切，为什么我有这些感觉。也许几个月的治疗和与友好民主党人的一些讨论，也许我会想通。
So why do you think you're having these feelings? Is it because of their ideas? Are you agreeing with them on the school voucher and on the 15% tax cut?
那你为什么认为你有这些感觉？是因为他们的主张吗？你是在学校代金券和15%减税上同意他们的看法吗？
No. You see, this is what's so strange about it, is that I still disagree with them as much as ever. I just like them more. I found that they're generally more truthful, easier to-- I've learned more from them. And I also feel like, it's easier to have an open discussion and disagree. With Democrats-- and maybe because they're in power in the White House, I'm covering a presidential campaign, it just always feels like this-- their careers are at stake whenever I'm talking to them. Whereas with a number of Republicans who I've been writing about, I feel like they're just talking to me, and making sense to me. And where we disagree, we can disagree.
不。你看，这就是为什么这很奇怪，我仍然像以前一样不同意他们。我只是更喜欢他们。我发现他们通常更真实，更容易——我从他们那里学到了更多。而且我也觉得，进行公开讨论并持不同意见更容易。对于民主党人——也许因为他们是在白宫掌权的，我报道的是总统竞选，它总是感觉像这样——只要我和他们交谈，他们的职业生涯就岌岌可危。而对于我一直在写的一批共和党人，我觉得他们只是在和我谈话，并且对我有意义。我们不同意的地方，我们可以不同意。
So do you feel like that's also a function of the fact that the Republicans are themselves more the party of ideas and more trying to work out their ideas of what it means to be a conservative? Does it mean you're more libertarian? Does it mean that you're more a fiscal conservative? Does it mean you're more Christian right kind of--
所以你是否觉得这也是因为共和党人本身就是更有主张的政党，并且更努力地思考作为保守派意味着什么？它意味着你更自由意志吗？它意味着你更财政保守吗？它意味着你更偏向基督教右派那种——
Oh, I think that's very true. I think it's completely true, that most of the interesting debate is taking place in the Republican Party. Where is the interesting debate about welfare reform? It should be in the Democratic Party, and it's not happening. There's a war in the Republican Party about abortion still, and about all sorts of related social issues. There are Republicans who will fight it out with Jack Kemp about supply-side economics.
哦，我认为那是真的。我认为这是完全正确的，大多数有趣的辩论都发生在共和党内。关于福利改革的有趣辩论在哪里？它应该在民主党内，但它没有发生。在共和党内，关于堕胎以及所有相关社会问题，依然存在战争。有共和党人会和杰克·肯普就供给侧经济学进行争论。
And on the Democratic side?
而在民主党方面呢？
Well, my feeling on the Democrat's side is just, right now it's all about winning, that no debate will happen until after November. It's very fallow on the Democratic side, not very interesting. You don't sit down with Democrats and have interesting discussions about policy.
嗯，我对民主党的感觉是，现在一切都是为了赢，11月之前不会发生任何辩论。民主党方面非常荒芜，不怎么有趣。你不会和民主党人坐下来进行关于政策的有趣讨论。
Michael Lewis. If you want a good time, pick up his book, Liar's Poker. He's assembling his Campaign Diaries in a new book. That'll be out some time.
迈克尔·刘易斯。如果你想找点乐子，读读他的书《说谎者的扑克》。他正在把他的《竞选日记》整理成一本新书。那会什么时候出来。
Act Three, Neighbors. You've probably heard at this point about the multimillion dollar cleanup Chicago has done for the convention, along the route between the downtown hotels, especially, and the United Center where the convention is held. Well, one night after the convention, I jumped into a cab with some other people, some strangers. We sped up Monroe Street, them to the hotels, me back to the radio studio. The moon was out, the air was perfect, the street was freshly paved.
第三幕，邻居。你可能已经听说过芝加哥为大会所做的价值数百万美元的清理工作，尤其是沿着市中心酒店到大会举办地联合中心之间的路线。好吧，大会结束后的一天晚上，我和其他人，一些陌生人跳进了一辆出租车。我们疾驰在门罗街上，他们去酒店，我回电台。月亮出来了，空气很完美，街道刚铺好。
And a woman from Washington, DC, a lobbyist, who had attended the convention in a sky box, remarked, "Chicago is so wonderful. There are no potholes, no homeless people, and the weather's so beautiful." I don't even know where to begin with that. I mean, I did not know that money could buy that amount of misinformation and misperception. I did not know that it was possible to create that. I'm sure you know about the weather, right? She's just as wrong about the potholes and the homeless people.
一位来自华盛顿特区的说客，一位曾在天空包厢参加大会的女性，评论道：“芝加哥真是太美妙了。没有坑洼，没有无家可归者，天气也太美好了。”我甚至不知道从哪里开始说起。我的意思是，我不知道钱能买到那么多的错误信息和误解。我不知道创造那个是可能的。我相信你知道天气的情况，对吧？她在坑洼和无家可归者问题上也同样错了。
Well, our next story is about our multimillion dollar civic cleanup. You may remember the bestselling book There Are No Children Here from a few years back. In There Are No Children Here , writer Alex Kotlowitz described the lives of two brothers at the Henry Horner homes. And the book was made into a TV film by Oprah Winfrey. It's been mentioned many times in speeches by Jack Kemp and others.
好了，我们的下一个故事是关于我们价值数百万美元的城市清理。你可能还记得几年前的畅销书《这里没有孩子》。在《这里没有孩子》中，作家亚历克斯·科特洛维茨描述了亨利·霍纳住宅区的两个兄弟的生活。这本书被奥普拉·温弗瑞改编成了电视电影。杰克·肯普和其他人在演讲中多次提到它。
Well, Henry Horner is the public housing project that sits directly across the street from the United Center. And when Chicago did its multimillion dollar cleanup for the Democratic Convention, it cleaned up some of Horner as part of it. Well, the boys from Alex Kotlowitz's book are now young men and they don't actually live at Horner anymore, though they go back every now and then. And one of them, Pharoah Walton, who's now 18, put together this story. He gives us a little tour of what has changed at Horner because of the convention, and what hasn't changed.
嗯，亨利·霍纳是坐落在联合中心正对面的公共住房项目。当芝加哥为民主党大会做价值数百万美元的清理工作时，它清理了部分霍纳作为其中的一部分。好吧，亚历克斯·科特洛维茨书中的男孩现在已经是年轻人了，他们实际上不再住在霍纳了，尽管他们时不时会回去。其中一个，现在18岁的法老·沃尔顿，整理了这个故事。他带我们参观了因为大会而改变的内容，以及什么没有改变。
When I left Henry Horner five years ago, it looked like a ghost town, no green grass, broken windows, graffiti everywhere. Now Henry Horner is a different place. There are rows of flowers outside the maintenance building, and new windows in the office where my mother used to pay rent. There are trees, new elevators. Most of the changes are on the side of the buildings that face the United Center. And on Washington Street, where the old [? Bernie ?] School used to be, there's a new playground, with a big lot and a huge, new blue and green jungle gym, nicer than any playground I've ever seen in the city, even on the north side, and everyone knows why.
五年前我离开亨利·霍纳时，它看起来像个鬼城，没有绿草，窗户破碎，到处都是涂鸦。现在亨利·霍纳是一个不同的地方。维护大楼外面有几排花，我母亲以前交房租的办公室有了新窗户。有树，有新电梯。大多数变化是在面向联合中心的大楼一侧。在以前的 [？伯尼？] 学校所在的华盛顿街，有一个新的游乐场，有一个大空地和一个巨大的、新的蓝绿色丛林健身架，比我在城里见过的任何游乐场都要好，即使是在北边，每个人都知道为什么。
I like it. It's fun. I know why they did it, because the president's coming. And then they'll all be taking kids and they gonna be killing people. The president [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
我喜欢它。它很有趣。我知道他们为什么这么做，因为总统要来了。然后他们都会带着孩子，他们会杀人。总统 [听不清]。
People say a lot of other things, too, and not all of them make sense, like what Canoe Howe told me about the playground.
人们还说了许多其他的事情，而且并非所有的事情都有意义，比如卡努·豪告诉我的关于游乐场的事。
The Democratic new convention coming. And now I can't be outside. [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] There going to be a lot of police in our building, and the president supposed to be in our building.
新的民主党大会要来了。现在我不能在外面了。[听不清短语] 我们大楼里会有很多警察，总统应该会在我们大楼里。
People at Horner are glad about the physical changes, but most of them say that they're mad that it took a president before the city would clean up a parking lot, or plant a tree. Some things at Henry Horner have changed, and some things are still the same, like shooters and hot days. When I was a kid, I would run in the house when the shooting started, same with my nephew, Snuggles, and his friend, Jeremy, today.
霍纳的人们对身体上的变化感到高兴，但他们中的大多数人说，他们很生气，因为直到总统到来之前，城市才清理了一个停车场，或者种了一棵树。亨利·霍纳的一些事情改变了，有些事情仍然一样，比如枪手和炎热的日子。当我还是个孩子时，射击开始时我会跑进屋里，今天我的侄子斯纳格尔斯和他的朋友杰里米也一样。
They always trying to shoot on a hot day.
他们总是在炎热的日子里试图开枪。
They start gang-banging whenever a hot day. And then all the kids gotta go in the house. Like two weeks ago, some girl got shot. She got shot in the eye.
他们一到热天就开始帮派火并。然后所有的孩子都必须进屋。就像两周前，有个女孩被枪击了。她的眼睛被击中了。
Probably dead now.
可能现在已经死了。
She is dead.
她确实死了。
They be shootin' all the time.
他们一直在开枪。
Over there.
在那边。
Usually, when you hear about the projects, you hear that things are bad and they're getting worse, but when I went to Horner, I heard a different story. There are still shootings, still drugs, still gangs, but mostly people told me that things have slowed down. In 1991, the residence of Henry Horner filed a lawsuit against the city and won. Because of that, the Chicago Housing Authority is cleaning it up, renovating old apartments, putting in a new elevators, tearing down the worst buildings. They've moved 233 families out of Horner since 1995, and installed 24-hour security guards. My friend Sylvia told me she feels safer.
通常，当你听说这些项目时，你会听到情况很糟糕，而且正在变得更糟，但当我去霍纳时，我听到了一个不同的故事。仍然有枪击，仍然有毒品，仍然有帮派，但大多数人告诉我情况已经放慢了。1991年，亨利·霍纳的居民对城市提起诉讼并胜诉。因此，芝加哥住房管理局正在清理它，翻修旧公寓，安装新电梯，拆除最糟糕的建筑。自1995年以来，他们已经将233户家庭迁出霍纳，并安装了24小时安全警卫。我的朋友西尔维娅告诉我她感到更安全了。
It's doing a lot better since 20 years it was looking around here, so crime gonna stop a lot better, too. They ain't doing too much shootin' or nothing, so it's good. Police are around a little more, so that's better, too, since they put that United Center out there, because they watch that a lot.
比起20年前，这里看起来好多了，所以犯罪率也会好很多。他们没怎么开枪或什么的，所以很好。警察也多了一点，所以这也更好，因为他们把那个联合中心放在那里，因为他们对那里看得很多。
Sylvia says police are always driving around the neighborhood since the United Center was built. Now, I visited my grandmother, and she said the same things, that things are getting better. We sat in her apartment, with gospel music on the radio and a preacher on the television, and she told me about life at Horner now.
西尔维娅说自从联合中心建成以来，警察一直在社区巡逻。现在，我去看了我的祖母，她也说了同样的话，情况正在好转。我们坐在她的公寓里，收音机里放着福音音乐，电视上播着牧师，她告诉我关于现在霍纳的生活。
But it's not too bad around here. I never read about nothing happening around here, like somebody getting killed in a drive-by shooting. It's not too bad. I walk out this house every day and those lights be out. I have to take a flashlight, but I'm not afraid. I'm not afraid. Of course, I got God, first of all.
但这附近还不是太糟。我从来没读到这附近发生了什么，比如有人在车内枪击中丧生。还不是太糟。我每天走出这个屋子，那些灯都是灭的。我不得不带个手电筒，但我并不害怕。我并不害怕。当然，我有上帝，首先。
One of the things that the president and the delegates at the convention won't see when they look at Horner from across the United Center parking lot is the Boys & Girls Club. Physically, the Boys & Girls Club hasn't changed since I was little-- old pool tables, a basketball court, cinderblock walls. It's not in great shape.
当总统和大会代表从联合中心停车场对面看霍纳时，他们看不到的一件事是男女童子军俱乐部。在身体上，男女童子军俱乐部自从我小时候就没变过——旧台球桌、篮球场、煤渣块墙。状况不是很好。
I talked to the grandfather of the community, Major Adams. He's worked at the Boys & Girls Club for 40 years. Everybody knows him and everybody respects him. Kids will listen to Major before they listen to teachers or parents or even the police. He's the only person at Horner who can walk into the middle of a gang fight and make it stop. In fact, he's famous for jumping into the middle of fights. And Major would be the first person to tell you about all the fights he's stopped.
我和社区的祖父，梅杰·亚当斯谈过。他在男女童子军俱乐部工作了40年。每个人都认识他，每个人都尊敬他。孩子们在听老师、父母甚至警察之前，会先听梅杰的。他是霍纳唯一一个能走进帮派斗争中间并让它停止的人。事实上，他以跳进争斗中间而闻名。梅杰将是第一个告诉你他停止的所有战斗的人。
He was going to jump on eight guys with these three knives. I didn't know he had three knives. But he had one in his hand. He was going to get these guys. So I had to grab this guy and take this knife away from him, while the guy-- I came out there, 12 of them was jumping on one guy. And it made me so mad. I said, "Well, look, I'm going to take all 12 of you guys one at a time." And I take them one at a time, and I whooped all 12 of them. I'm going to do it by myself. I picked him up and throwed him over the fence. I'm telling you, you've got to--
他要拿着这三把刀跳向八个人。我不知道他有三把刀。但他手里有一把。他要去找这些人。所以我必须抓住这个人并从他手中夺走这把刀，当那个人——我走到外面时，有12个人正在围攻一个人。这让我很生气。我说，“好吧，看，我要一个一个地收拾你们这12个人。”我一个一个地收拾他们，我把他们12个全都教训了一顿。我要自己做这件事。我抓住他把他扔过栅栏。我告诉你，你必须——
Some people say the neighborhood is safer because over 200 families moved out. There are fewer people to get in trouble or shoot each other. My friend Sylvia says people have less time to fool around because the housing authority is hiring residents to do construction and clean the place up. Another friend of mine says people are getting their act together because now the city is kicking people out and tearing buildings down. And they don't want to lose their homes. But the way Major sees it, the neighborhood is better because there are people in Horner who are trying to make a difference.
有些人说社区更安全了，因为有200多户家庭搬走了。惹麻烦或互相射击的人少了。我的朋友西尔维娅说，人们没时间瞎混，因为住房管理局雇佣居民进行建设并清理这个地方。我的另一个朋友说，人们开始步入正轨，因为现在城市正在把人赶走并拆除建筑。他们不想失去家园。但按照梅杰的看法，社区变得更好是因为霍纳有试图做出改变的人。
I'll tell you, crime has went down in our neighborhood, this neighborhood, because you have a guy like me working in the neighborhood. When you walk in here, a lot of them gang-bangers just came, I fed them. So there's a lot of things I do for them. I let them play basketball. When they want to go back to school, I see that they go back to school. They go to jail, I send them money and stuff like that.
我告诉你，犯罪率在我们的社区，这个社区下降了，因为有像我这样的人在社区工作。当你走进这里时，许多帮派分子刚来，我喂饱了他们。所以我为他们做了很多事。我让他们打篮球。当他们想回到学校时，我确保他们回到学校。他们进了监狱，我给他们寄钱之类的东西。
Like my Aunt Milly says, you can't beautify the outside when the inside ain't right. Major is working hard to beautify the inside.
就像我姑妈米莉说的，当内在不正确时，你不能美化外部。梅杰正在努力美化内在。
In the main room at the Boys & Girls Club, there's a trophy case. Inside, there are all the trophies won by Horner baseball teams, basketball teams, and football teams. And pinned to the back of the trophy case, there are pictures of Horner residents who've made something of their lives, who've gotten out of the projects, went on to do great things.
在男女童子军俱乐部的主房间里，有一个奖杯柜。里面装满了霍纳棒球队、篮球队和足球队赢得的所有奖杯。奖杯柜后面贴着霍纳居民的照片，他们成就了自己的生活，走出了项目，去做了伟大的事情。
All three of those young men up there are teachers. They grew up in the area.
那上面的三个年轻人都是老师。他们在该地区长大。
Those three up there?
那上面的那三个？
Yeah, those three there. And this is Dr. Steven Parker at Chicago State. That's Verdine from Earth, Wind, & Fire.
是的，那三个。这是芝加哥州立大学的史蒂文·帕克博士。那是来自“地球、风与火”乐队的佛丁。
Then he pointed out a blank spot and asked me for a picture, his way of saying he knew I was going to make it.
然后他指着一个空白处，向我要一张照片，这是他表达他知道我能成功的方式。
Pharoah Walton. He's a senior at Culver Academy in Indiana. He asked us to play some of this song after his story.
法老·沃尔顿。他是印第安纳州卡尔弗学院的高年级学生。他要求我们在他的故事后播放这首歌的一部分。
[MUSIC - "THE GHETTO" BY TOO SHORT]
[音乐 - Too Short的“贫民窟”]
Act Four, TV Show. Danny Drennan is, as far as we can tell, an expert on two things in this world-- the worldwide web and the TV show Beverly Hills, 90210. I feel like we're going from the sublime to the ridiculous here. He created one of the more interesting and eccentric pages on the worldwide web, a weekly wrap-up of 90210 in a very unusual style. He writes about television in a way that no one else does, and a couple weeks ago we asked him to review a Bob Dole appearance when Bob Dole appeared on Larry King Live . For this week, we asked him to review the Democratic National Convention.
第四幕，电视节目。丹尼·德南是，据我们所知，在这个世界上精通两件事的专家——万维网和电视节目《飞越比弗利》。我觉得我们在这里从崇高走向了荒谬。他在万维网上创建了一个更有趣和古怪的页面，以一种非常不寻常的风格每周总结90210。他以一种没人做过的方式书写电视，几周前我们请他评论鲍勃·多尔在《拉里·金现场秀》上的表现。本周，我们请他评论民主党全国代表大会。
So I'm watching the Democratic National Convention the other night on C-SPAN, and let me just say how thankful I am that C-SPAN exists. The best part of the convention is when everyone is going home and all the other networks have moved on to other things, but there's good old gavel-to-gavel C-SPAN still filming every last bit, including interviews with teenage convention volunteers who refused entrance to one of the Gore daughters because she didn't have her ID with her.
所以那天晚上我在C-SPAN上看民主党全国代表大会，让我说一下我是多么感谢C-SPAN的存在。大会最好的部分是每个人都在回家，所有其他电视网都转向了其他事情，但还有老派的从头到尾的C-SPAN仍然在拍摄每一个片段，包括对拒绝一名戈尔女儿入场的青少年大会志愿者的采访，因为她没带身份证。
And C-SPAN also does this great phone interview thing where people from Canada can call up and tell America how much they hate our political conventions. How about you mind your own business up there in Canada? And stop reminding us that liberal is not an epithet in Canada, and about gun control in Canada, and about health care in Canada, and about all the other things the Democrats should be doing here that already exist in Canada. I'm totally convinced that people from the Canadian tourist board or whatever are constantly calling up C-SPAN pretending to be interested in American politics to try and convince Americans to move up north.
C-SPAN也做这种很棒的电话采访，加拿大人可以打电话过来告诉美国他们是多么讨厌我们的政治大会。你们在加拿大那边管好自己的事怎么样？别再提醒我们要么“自由主义”在加拿大不是一个绰号，关于加拿大的枪支管制、关于加拿大的医疗保健，以及关于民主党在这里应该做而加拿大已经存在的所有其他事情。我完全相信来自加拿大旅游局或什么的那些人一直在打电话给C-SPAN，假装对美国政治感兴趣，以试图说服美国人搬到北方去。
And the other thing I like about C-SPAN is that it gets all the unscripted bits, like Hillary Clinton waiting for her cue to start talking, but then jumping the gun and then stopping, and then going "great" under her breath, totally angry, and then starting again and delivering her lines all deadpan, like so ticked off that she just made a fool of herself on live television.
我喜欢C-SPAN的另一件事是它捕捉到了所有非脚本片段，比如希拉里·克林顿等待她的提示开始说话，但随后抢了先，然后停下来，然后嘀咕了一句“太棒了”，完全愤怒，然后重新开始，面无表情地传递她的台词，好像因为她在现场电视上出丑而非常生气。
So later on, we get a big, old tribute to former Commerce Secretary Ron Brown, with a video of people saying nice things about Ron Brown, and then his widow, Alma Brown, talking about her husband. But then, all of a sudden, we switch to the Alma Brown variety hour, because in the middle of talking about her deceased husband, Alma Brown up and introduces Kenny G. How scary is that, to be talking about your dead husband one minute, and then to have to introduce some god-awful white jazz musician the next? If you combined the Lawrence Welk Show with Rod Serling's Night Gallery , you would get Alma Brown introducing Kenny G at the Democratic National Convention.
所以后来，我们得到了一个对前商务部长罗恩·布朗的隆重致敬，视频中有人们说着罗恩·布朗的好话，然后他的遗孀阿尔玛·布朗谈论她的丈夫。但是然后，突然，我们切换到阿尔玛·布朗综艺节目，因为在谈论她已故丈夫的同时，阿尔玛·布朗站起来介绍了肯尼·G。谈论你的亡夫一分钟，下一分钟不得不介绍一些糟糕透顶的白人爵士音乐家，这有多可怕？如果你把劳伦斯·威尔克秀和罗德·瑟林的作品《夜间画廊》结合起来，你就会得到民主党全国代表大会上阿尔玛·布朗介绍肯尼·G的画面。
And if I were Kenny G, I would seriously fire my agent. The only gigs that Kenny G gets are the Democratic National Convention and Kelly Taylor's birthday party on Beverly Hills, 90210. And even more upsetting, perhaps, is the whole Hollywoodization of the political process. I mean, can I just ask how much plastic surgery did that house minority leader guy, Richard Gephardt, have done?
如果我是肯尼·G，我会认真地解雇我的经纪人。肯尼·G能得到的唯一演出是民主党全国代表大会和《飞越比弗利》中凯莉·泰勒的生日派对。而且更令人不安的，也许是政治过程完全的“好莱坞化”。我的意思是，我可以问一下众议院少数党领袖理查德·格普哈特做了多少整容手术吗？
And how many so-called Hollywood stars could they bring in to speak during the convention? Like Edward James Olmos, who came up with the most brilliantly obtuse quote of the evening when he said, and I quote, "the complexity of this question is so intense that I could never try to attempt to answer it." That is a direct quote. What does that mean? And do I really need Edward James Olmos passionately giving me a definition of what dissing means?
他们能带来多少所谓的“好莱坞明星”在大会期间发言？像爱德华·詹姆斯·奥莫斯，他给出了那个晚上最聪明但最迟钝的引语，当他说，我引用，“这个问题的复杂性太强烈了，以至于我永远无法尝试回答它。”那是一个直接引语。那是什么意思？我真的需要爱德华·詹姆斯·奥莫斯充满激情地给我定义什么是“诋毁”吗？
And someone should also probably talk to Christopher Reeve's manager. I mean, I hate to say it, but how much in common with the so-called people does a rich, overpaid, covered-by-health-insurance actor who broke his neck while enjoying some totally elitist equestrian sport have? And maybe the producers of this convention, who also produce the Oscars, where Reeve also appeared, gave Christopher Reeve, a three-engagement deal or something. Or maybe Christopher Reeve just sells his Nielsen share to the highest bidder.
而且有人也应该去和克里斯托弗·里夫的经理谈谈。我的意思是，我不喜欢说，但一个富有的、薪水过高、有医疗保险覆盖、在享受某种完全精英主义马术运动时摔断脖子的演员，和所谓的“人民”有多少共同之处？也许这个大会的制作人，他们也制作奥斯卡奖，里夫也出现在那里，给了克里斯托弗·里夫一份三场演出的协议之类的。或者也许克里斯托弗·里夫只是把他的尼尔森份额卖给出价最高的人。
And let me just say, if I had to labor with every single solitary breath just to speak three words at a time, and then wait because everyone in the audience takes that as a cue to clap even though I haven't finish my point yet, I sure as hell wouldn't waste that breath on Bill Clinton. So then we get about five million people plugging Hillary Clinton's book. And then later, the convention moves on to the politically expedient death and personal medical catastrophe part of the show, exemplified by Al Gore's kid and sister and every other speaker this evening. Like there's nothing about Clinton that tugs our heart strings, so they have to bring in all these death and tragedy stories that have absolutely nothing to do with him.
让我说，如果我必须用每一次呼吸才能一次说出三个词，然后等待因为观众里的每个人都把它当作鼓掌的提示，即使我还没完成我的观点，我肯定不会把呼吸浪费在比尔·克林顿身上。所以然后我们看到大约五百万人都在推销希拉里·克林顿的书。然后后来，大会进入了政治上权宜之计的死亡和个人医疗灾难的部分，以阿尔戈尔的孩子、姐妹和那天晚上的每一位其他演讲者为例。就像克林顿身上没有什么能拉动我们的心弦，所以他们不得不带来所有这些与他毫无关系的死亡和悲剧故事。
And so then we see Sarah Brady and her husband, Jim, and I'm sure that Sarah Brady meant well, moving her husband, Jim, around the convention stage like a living political prop, and talking about the Brady Bill and gun control. But if you look at Bill Clinton's track record so far, you might worry that gun control is just another step in Bill Clinton's goal to declare a national state of emergency and establish martial law in this country. He already wants to set up curfews, and he's already responsible for the biggest increase in FBI wiretapping in American history, and he wants to take away guns, and he wants to put more cops on the street, and the political protesters at the convention were supposed to be content with receiving a lottery-derived slot of time for them to protest.
所以我们看到了莎拉·布雷迪和她的丈夫吉姆，我肯定莎拉·布雷迪本意是好的，把她的丈夫吉姆像一个活生生的政治道具一样在大会舞台上推来推去，谈论布雷迪法案和枪支管制。但如果你看看比尔·克林顿到目前为止的记录，你可能会担心枪支管制只是比尔·克林顿宣布国家紧急状态并在该国建立戒严令的目标的又一步。他已经想设立宵禁，而且他已经应对了美国历史上FBI监听的最大增长，他想拿走枪支，他想在街上放更多的警察，而大会上的政治抗议者本应该满足于得到一个通过彩票抽签得到的抗议时间槽。
Could someone please clue me in to the moment in time when the Constitution of the United States started parceling out the First Amendment on a time-sharing basis? Are we going to have alternate side of the street freedom of speech at some point soon? And this is from the Democrats. And if you think I'm crazy, just count the number of times that Bill Clinton mentions the 21st century and new technology. How annoying is it when Bill Clinton goes on and on about wanting to hook up every school to the so-called information superhighway, when in reality the internet is a huge dumping ground of useless information? I mean, kids can't even read or write, but let's hook them up to the biggest waste of technology going. Of course, only after we sensor it.
有人能告诉我美国宪法开始在时间共享的基础上分配第一修正案的那一刻吗？我们很快就会有“街道轮流自由言论”吗？这是来自民主党人的。如果你认为我疯了，就数数比尔·克林顿提到21世纪和新技术的次数。当比尔·克林顿喋喋不休地想把每所学校都连接到所谓的“信息高速公路”时，是多么令人讨厌，而在现实中，互联网是一个无用信息的巨大垃圾场？我的意思是，孩子们甚至不会阅读或写作，但让我们把他们连接到正在进行的最大技术浪费上。当然，只有在我们审查它之后。
And if I were paranoid, I would say that Bill Clinton is, in fact, Big Brother, who wants to preside over a hugely illiterate population, tied into the government via government-censored internet links, gunless and with cops at every street corner, entertained and sedated by Hollywood has-beens, in order to pave the way for his beast of the apocalypse, one-world government takeover. And maybe moving to Canada isn't such a bad idea after all.
如果我是偏执狂，我会说比尔·克林顿实际上是“老大哥”，他想统治一个巨大的文盲群体，通过政府审查的互联网链接与政府绑定，没有枪，每个街角都有警察，被好莱坞过气明星娱乐和镇静，以便为他的启示录怪兽，世界政府接管铺平道路。也许搬到加拿大毕竟不是什么坏主意。
Danny Drennan's website, www.inquisitor.com. Proceed at your own risk.
丹尼·德南的网站，www.inquisitor.com。请自行承担风险继续。
Our program was produced today by Peter Clowney and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin.
我们的节目今天由彼得·克劳尼和我自己制作，阿里克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。特约编辑，保罗·托夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
If you would like a copy of this program, it's only $10. Call us on the phone at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380.
如果您想要一份该节目的副本，只需10美元。请拨打芝加哥WBEZ电台电话312-832-3380。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I am Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。